One of the most important and simplest
ways to ensure your system is secure
is to keep your software up
to date with new releases.
Because Linux systems focus on
reliability and they run a variety of
complex applications that have numerous
dependencies of their own, most Linux
distributions do not auto-update
the software installed on the system.
You'll need to do this yourself and
test your apps to make sure any recent
updates don't break your application.
The first step to upgrading your
installed software is to update your
package source list.
We do this with the command
sudo apt-get update.
See the sudo there?
We have to run this as the root user.
The update command will run through all
of the repositories we saw within our
etc/app/sources.list file, and it will
check to see what all software is
available and
what those version numbers are.
This command doesn't actually
perform any changes to the software
on your system.
It just makes sure your system is
aware of the latest information stored
within all of these repositories
that you're making use of.